now on impeachment as you know the house
is expected to vote on the articles of
impeachment this week assuming the
articles are a downed Lee that the trial
must be fair and it's very important
that the American people judging to be
fair a fair trial is one where senators
get all the facts and one that allows
them to adjudicate the case impartially
two weeks ago now
I told Leader McConnell I was ready to
discuss trial rules instead of talking
to me
he spoke publicly about what a trial may
look like and said he was taking his
cues from the White House it was very
partisan very slanted very unfair so to
get things back on track Oh
was last night outlining a very
reasonable structure that would result
in a fair trial this morning I sent a
letter to every United States Senator
Democrat and Republican I hope that all
of my colleagues will look at this
proposed structure and make up their own
minds the four witnesses we propose have
direct knowledge of why the aid to
Ukraine was delayed we don't know what
kind of evidence they will present they
might present exculpatory evidence that
helps President Trump it may be
incriminating against the president but
they should be heard but by virtue of
the senior administration positions they
occupy each of them will have
information to share about the charges
made by the house information that no
one has heard at this point in fact in
the case of mr. Bolton his attorney
stated publicly that he has additional
relevant information to share
information that has not yet become
public
how on such a weighty matter could we
avoid hearing this could we go forward
without hearing it and that is why I
sent the letter to impart to leader
McConnell we also propose that subpoenas
for documents that are directly related
to the charges brought by the house come
forward there's always a lot of
attention on the question of witnesses
but these documents are also of great
importance when it comes to making sure
senators have what they need to make a
fully informed decision right now I
think the house has amassed a great deal
of evidence much of it in the form of
testimony from the president's own
appointees that the president committed
impeachable offenses but a good number
of my Republican colleagues have said
they believe the charges are serious but
there isn't enough evidence yet for them
to make a decision we believe these
witnesses and documents would provide
the evidence they're looking for without
being dilatory or letting the trial drag
on for too long I haven't seen a single
good argument about why these witnesses
shouldn't testify or these documents be
produced unless the president has
something to hide and his supporters
want that information hidden the trial
structure I outlined in my letter to
leader McConnell will ensure that all
the relevant facts come out without
dilatory action you know there is a
grand American tradition of a speedy and
fair trial that's just what we've
proposed here and I expect Republicans
would be sympathetic to our proposal for
that reason the President and House
Republicans have resisted letting all
the evidence and facts come out the
president hasn't offered a single
exculpatory
of evidence that refutes what's in the
house impeachment charges they have not
refuted them our document could be
summed up by Joe Friday on dragnet just
the facts ma'am that's what we're
interested in not diversions not
conspiracy theories that are irrelevant
to the case just the facts ma'am as I
said the president has offered nothing
exculpatory to disprove the evidence
that has been put forward instead he's
orchestrated a cover-up it's left many
in the Senate and millions across the
country asking what is the president
hiding why doesn't he want the facts to
come out in their investigation the
House compiled and presented an enormous
amount of evidence in support of the
articles of impeachment but as I said
some of my Republican colleagues are
saying there isn't enough evidence the
trial structure I outlined in my letter
to leader McConnell will ensure all the
facts come out so in the coming weeks
senators particularly Republican
senators will have a choice do they want
a fair honest trial that examines all
the facts or they do they want a trial
that doesn't let the facts come out
trials have witnesses that's what trials
are all about and documents it's not
just the prosecutors in this case the
house attorneys make their side
the president's lawyers make their side
we know that already we've heard that we
need to know the facts from those who
are in a position to know and from
documents that accurately reflect them
so to engage a trial without the facts
coming out is to engage in a cover-up
to conduct a trial without the facts is
saying we're afraid we have something to
hide
to conduct a trial without relevant
witnesses who haven't been heard from to
just rehash the evidence presented in
the house just doesn't make any sense
if leader McConnell doesn't hold a full
and fair trial the American people will
rightly ask what are you leader
McConnell and what it's president Trump
hiding ready for questions but one at a
time no okay here is what I said at the
time these are exactly my words my view
is we've heard from most of these
witnesses over and over again we've
heard the same story the witnesses in 99
had already been given had already given
grand jury testimony we knew what they
were to say the four witnesses we've
called have not been heard from that is
the the difference and it's a difference
that is totally overwhelming well I'm
look I'm not gonna second-guess the
house there is virtually no argument no
good argument if you
well um look I'm not gonna second-guess
the house there is virtually no argument
no good argument if you expect to have
the support from Democrats and
Republicans because the argument is so
strong and many Republicans have voiced
to me and many of my colleagues
privately but they think what the
president did is wrong but they're just
not sure enough facts have been
presented to make the an impeachable
case high crimes and misdemeanors this
is the way to do it the way we outlined
these right these are the four who have
the most direct contact of the facts
that are in dispute most particularly
why was the aid to Ukraine delayed these
these are the best four witnesses for
that case and by the way we don't want
to be dilatory we don't want to stress
this out any longer than we have to but
these people are crucial and haven't
been heard from and again that's the
difference with 1999 and it's a total
difference yes I'm not going to get into
that I'll negotiate with McConnell but
let me tell you live testimony is the
best way to go
you can't say despite what I said that's
the whole case we've heard from them
[Laughter]
1999 1999 was a different case there
were all the obvious reasons why they
did not want a witness like Monica
Lewinsky testifying in public I was
there and it related to what she what
the questions might be about that the
whole nation including children would be
watching it's totally different
situation there's no analogy the bottom
line is that there are some who say
there are some who may think it's enough
we all have to wait and not prejudge the
case but there are many who have said
these are serious charges but I'm not
sure there's enough factual evidence to
merit impeachment these people know
better than anybody else the facts there
is no reason on God's green earth why
they shouldn't be called and testify
unless you're afraid of what they might
say where we'll cross that I am hopeful
leader McConnell has finally said that
he wants to sit down and talk and I am I
am very eager and willing to do that as
I said we want to come up with a fair
trial where we'll cross that I am
hopeful leader McConnell has finally
said that he wants to sit down and talk
and I am I am very eager and willing to
do that as I said we want to come up
with a fair trial with her
well again I think the trial should be
focused on the facts that the house
presented not on conspiracy theories
that some established liar puts forward
and then someone says let's hear if that
conspiracy theory is correct which has
no relevance to the facts here so we
ought to stick to the facts and if there
are other witnesses who might have
witnessed what happened who might have
very strong evidence on the facts that
the house presented I'd certainly want
to hear who they are thank you everybody
[Music]